so president trump has sent a cease and
desist letter to the rnc saying that
they can't use his name and likeness
for fundraising purposes trump has sent
many seasoned assist letters in the past
and often they have resulted in
absolutely nothing whatsoever so you
might think that this cease and desist
letter
is also meritless but there might
actually be something to this
just because trump was president doesn't
mean he can't use his name and likeness
anymore
individuals often can control the
monetization of their likeness
now some jurisdictions say that if you
are a celebrity or a politician
you can't sue for misappropriation of
likeness you're a public figure
but most jurisdictions say that even
politicians or celebrities can still
monetize and control the use of their
likeness it just depends on whether
their likeness is being used for
exploitative purposes or not
and fundraising emails from the rnc
probably qualify as exploitative
and trump might be on legal footing if
he wants to prevent them from using his
name
and likeness so this likeness is telling
you to subscribe or i will see you
in court